[Music]
you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
incredible french stewart
from 30 rock from the sun that's what i
called it the entire episode from third
rock from the sun but also countless
other things he's always incredible we
actually met doing an episode of how we
roll he was such a delight to work with
of course i was already a fan and was
aware of his incredible work
so
unprepared for how great he would be on
this podcast though he came in and he
absolutely destroyed you're about to see
it's silly it's light it's fun it's
interesting it's thoughtful and he has a
great god answer at the end which i
really really enjoyed so it was just a
delight it was one of those did we just
become best friends sort of episodes so
i can't wait to get to it only a couple
things to plug up top july 12th is my
next stand-up show that's the only date
i have right now if you're going to be
in the los angeles area go to largo
dashla.com for tickets always always
always an incredible time
uh i'm a little tired so i can't
remember who did it the last one but it
was
i don't know we've had dimitri martin
judd apatow
uh
sarah silverman zach galfinakis it's
always incredible any show at largo is
great but if you want to see me do uh
usually about 45 minutes to stand up
and then have some guests as well go to
largo dash la.com and whenever you see
this episode or watch or listen to this
episode i do it monthly and it's always
great to have weirdos in the audience so
please please please come check it out
and if you like the show why not support
it and try a pete's pick like i'm
wearing it right now look at the video
so i can show you how stretchy how
stretchy
how stretchy my my freaking jeans are
these aren't just regular jeans these
are the per look at that look at that
can you see that these are the perfect
jeans for the perfectly imperfect man as
you know if you listen to my stand up i
hate hard pants i don't understand how
it's 20 22 and we haven't figured out
how to look good but also wear
comfortable pants that don't scrunch up
where they're not supposed to scrunch up
turns out we have figured it out we have
the perfect jean they have a great look
they're my best looking jeans but they
are the best fitting and best feeling
jeans that have incredible incredible
craftsmanship i've every pair i have i
haven't had to replace one yet and i
wear them almost every single day
they're so comfortable they're almost
like pajama pants you could sleep in
them because they are two percent
spandex it's like a stretchy little
secret you can't tell these are 2
spandex and 2.5 rayon for extra comfort
and movement that your man parts require
these are the most comfortable pants
i've ever owned in my life these jeans
stretch so you're not saying crushed
thereby providing the only true home for
your bone this is the only ad i love to
do because it has the word thereby in it
thereby providing the only true home for
your bone they're super soft you may
even forget you're wearing pants they're
maximum maximum durability i mean these
are really made utilizing the highest
quality materials and sewing techniques
that provide you with a product that is
built to last and best of all they're
not khakis [__] your khakis spare your
nuts the perfect jean for the
imperfectly imperfect men just 60 bucks
when you use promo code weirdo at
checkout liberate your lower limbs with
the one and only perfect jean whether
you're working with lampton lemons or
lentils a three leaf clover or a big old
honkin eggplant the perfect jean has you
covered take a peek at
www.theperfectgene.nyc
that's www.theperfectgene.nyc
code weirdo at checkout for 25 off and
show your support of the show
this episode is also brought to us by
literally
the thing that i recommend more in life
to my friends and my colleagues is magic
mind i just got a text today from my
friend jimmy he's a photographer and a
director and he said that this product
that i recommended to him was the
biggest game changer of 2022 so far and
i absolutely for real four-wheel agree
with him magic mind is the world's first
productivity drink it is a mix of 12
functional ingredients including matcha
which has endotropics so matcha which
has natural adaptogens which help us
cope with stress and also just tend to
round out the edges of the caffeine
we're consuming so you drink this while
you're taking your coffee while you're
having your tea whatever it might be
that you have caffeine in the morning
the adaptogens in the matcha that are in
magic mine are going to round it out and
make it an even more steady
dialed in not jacked up but like a
dialed in
flow state that's what this is this is
flow state in a bottle whenever i'm
sitting down to write
when i'm doing an episode of this
podcast i drink one of these 10 minutes
beforehand and it helps me feel
dialed in not wired dialed in it has
nootropics which is like you know
vitamins for your brain basically that
help you focus and adaptogens that help
you fight off stress can be taken daily
for a sharper mind steady energy immune
support and less stress and you get 30
percent more done on average that's five
to seven hours of 30 more productivity
after drinking magic mind is the morning
drink for creators entrepreneurs and
freelancers athletes have gatorade we
now have creator aid it's a creator's
best friend try it 15 to 30 minutes
before recording or producing an episode
of a podcast like this writing a script
uh anything that you're doing that uses
your brain that needs your energy that
needs you happy that needs you light
that needs you locked in and in the flow
this stuff fights off procrastination
brain fog fatigue and some add symptoms
and helps you get into that flow state
and even better the more you use it the
better it works they also have a money
back guarantee which means any first
purchase will be refunded no questions
asked if it doesn't meet your
expectations and we actually have a
special offer for weirdos from our
friends at magic mind all you have to do
is go to magic mind dot co
slash weird and use our discount code
weird at checkout to get 20 off your
first order that's www dot magic mind
dot co slash weird and use discount code
weird at checkout for 20 off i seriously
val loves it i love it it's a huge game
changer in my life and it would be a
great way to support the show and we
always always always appreciate that and
of course support yourself at the same
time all right everybody let's enjoy
french stewart together what a great
episode so glad you're here hope to see
you july 12th at largo in the meantime
i'll get into it
sorry there's a step there and
welcome
to the sauna that's the sauna frenchie
first of all let's get these great
greetings on the air because i said get
in here you living legend and you said
you lanky yeti
you're a big feel like is the right way
to start i think it's the the best way
to start
i'm just gonna offer it to you get your
shoes on the couch curl up on however
you're comfortable
yeah
also it's just a warning that the couch
is filthy but like it's not that it's
like a sleepover i've seen worse
i mean i've seen way worse come on
i've been to leno's house like you
should immediately throw jay leno under
the bus yeah i don't know how to do that
no add you to his home no have you been
to jay leno's house what a weird first
question dang it
no why
and now my feelings are hurt because
like jane i know hasn't invited me to
his house man i i've never even met jay
leno i've been in showbiz for a long
time
now i've been on a parallel path to jay
leno yeah you're vertical with your
political yeah yeah that's the same
ocean he's just swimming over here yeah
you're you're just propelling yourselves
you know down down the line that's right
yeah
tell me i did a show once
the the tonight show with jay leno yeah
yes
not fun i don't like it you didn't like
it i didn't tell me why well it was just
like it's okay by the way we're gonna
let you off the hook mr leno because if
you do three million of something every
once in a while it's not gonna be great
you know what i'm saying yeah like this
is life this is life that's the feeling
of life you can't always be great so it
is okay tell me why you hated it it's
the truth of life it's the it's the
truth of life french we want to win win
win win win win but unfortunately
tonight it's this sometimes it goes
squirrely and it's and if it's not going
squarely it's probably about to go
squirrely
it's inches from squarely inches from
squirrely is now the name of this
episode or if you live in um europe it's
centimeters from squirrely
you see what i'm saying i have never
needed something more i didn't realize
until you said that i did actually when
you walked in
yeah you get it i get it but i need a
hang and i'm glad we're hanging a buddy
hang on a buddy hang on we're getting
even not to bring gender into it but a
bro hang feel free but
we're hanging with her too katie's
always here i feel like she's good and i
bro
i like a lot of bro things let's not get
to that tell me
i don't think i'm a bro but i like a lot
of broad things we're going to put a pin
in that we'll put a pin in the bro thing
ouch
oh that would
oh that would hurt
i should pay you thousands of dollars
like that was such a great read on oh
that got hurt like that was like that
should be someone's ringtone yeah
because i i thought about my penis and
you thought about your ding-dong yeah
added value i'm gonna sell it as an nft
no one can fudge that token oh you're
gonna say they're gonna punch my oh they
can't find yet
they can't punch it tell me why you tell
me fungible you're unfungible okay i've
always said that about you and ron is
unfunctionable tell me run run punches i
didn't know if he'd get it
[Music]
send this clip to ron punches um ron
funches is a wonderful comedian that you
would love tell me why you didn't like
jay leno just because it's so fun
well
because like he was like like he would
like what he would do is he would do uh
he would just pre-read he's not like you
you we we just go in and we see china i
knew you were going to say this not just
about leno but a bad late night
appearance with any of them right is
when you feel like oh they didn't find
the magic today they didn't find the
gratitude or or the novelty and they're
just stuck in a talk show
maybe they're going to talk show they're
stuck in a dog show nightmare it's a
talk show nightmare and it was like it
was one of those things
yeah he pre-interviews me within an inch
of my damn life
and before the camera was on yeah before
the camera's on and then what i do is i
go in and he knows what story i'm gonna
tell
and then he beats me to the punch line
i have to and so then he's like and what
what what else do you want to say yeah
for this moment is
and what else you got
is that what he said yeah okay so you
what what story did you tell do you
remember i can't even remember but he
knew the punchline he knew the punchline
he told it before me and he got in a
1981 porsche carrera right zoom to front
yes he got in a 1956 ferrari here we go
better
i went to a like what's a good car 81
carrera he got into a
1966 uh pontiac tempest
[Laughter]
i don't know what he did and he zoomed
around and he zoomed around and took did
he take your punchline
i'm gonna say we could take him to not
real court but the people's court like
people comedy court we could take him to
judge judy's comedy court is that your
phone you gotta you gotta put it on do
not cause i'm gonna be answering your
texts
you know what i'm not even mad about it
i'm just telling you let's see who it is
okay let's see who it is oh it's just my
wife i'm gonna turn it off
how about that
how about that i just dissed my wife
oh anything for the show anything for
this anything for the show i don't care
throw miss did she take your name
yeah she took my name miss stewart throw
her under the bus i'm gonna throw
vanessa claire stewart that's her full
government but i'm throwing her ass
under the bus because it's the show can
i ask you something before we get back
to jay leno which we will look at this
oh leno any patrick's in your family
any patrick's patrick stewart oh no
hello french hello hello french
i love third rock from the sunday
because earth
is in outer space which is where my show
was
actually all shows are in outer space oh
my
god
i'm so sorry what a way to force my
impression in no no i'm letting you i'm
littleing you you know
which doesn't mean we're bros just
because it has balls doesn't mean it's
bros
are we bras
i would wear a bra because
we're supportive
that was a seinfeld episode we could use
a little support
which brings us to son of a frenchie
stew
damn it you were on seinfeld right there
on radford i was there for like i was i
was uh i was on seinfeld
in the same day that i was on the larry
sanders show
that's a great showbiz day it's it's a
great little uh bangabang bangabang
is that a yes that's when you have
chinese food and then you go eat a full
pizza
it's bang bang oh bang bang yeah bang
bang oh yeah yeah yeah yeah not china
not because it's chinese bang bang i'm
like that's that's the show
i i saw it on the show louis yeah noted
that they caught bang bang when you go
and eat a full meal and then you go eat
a full meal that's right that's what you
did you had a full meal and you bang
banged it was a showbiz uh bang bang you
show biz bang bang which sounds
like an illuminati sort of again we're
both gonna be cancelled because
i'm just a misunderstanding really we're
really misunderstanding so so which one
did you do first and were they both in
radford they were both on radford wow
and so it was one of those things where
it was like i was doing larry sanders
show and i was playing a character
called the weird intern weird intern at
least he's not weird in turn number one
you were the only weird intern i was the
only weirdo your agent said we'll do it
but get rid of weird in turn number two
just there's no combine the lines put it
together i know one of them's nervous
and one of them's excited but make him
excited nervous and french will do it
you can't have too excited or weird
weird
no kind of an insult no i'm not gonna no
no no i'm the weird intern he only does
single intern and the the storyline
the storyline was is that he uh larry
sanders had had an anal fissure
oh and so they sent the weird intern out
what is an anal fissure
it sounds like it it's something you do
to fix a television reception like we
need an anal fissure to do this staticky
shot if you can figure out why i thought
that's what it was i know it also sounds
like a fish hook up your butt no it's a
it's a it's a rip in your butthole it's
a rip i'm just going to be direct yes
please speak to me like you're my doctor
but you're also my bro and so my only
it's a rip in your butthole my only line
was here's your buck cream larry and
would you like some frozen yogurt for
after the show
like that was my line
well it used to be weird and turn number
one said here's your butt cream larry
weird enter number two she said would
you like any presents but they looked at
the finances and they were like we gotta
crush this together into one weird
internship one weird intern
absolutely for finances for the finance
sector for the sake of financing
i'm happy that we're both sort of show
business bankers
at the moment we like we're just
balancing budgets you mean balancing
budgets making sense of the script bell
budge bell budge well you've been around
man you you have to come into a project
now look at a script you're doing mom
yeah or as they call it in minnesota
ma'am ma'am you're doing that hit show
man
let's go get a bagel and a sword on
watch ma'am
oh french stewart from third rock is on
ma'am nice delightful oh and he's also
in that youtube bee's episode of
seinfeld actually i think it's juicy
fruits
[Laughter]
i i really loved him in beverly hills
chihuahua too
that's right
video inspector gadget was absolutely i
can't come without thinking i can't do
it the new wkrp in cincinnati i'm like
in everything that
like the original like there will be
a there will be a hit and then
there's a janky follow-up
yes that's that's where i call weird
intern number one that's right for the
janky follower for the janky follow-up
yeah and and
none of the original cast members will
have anything to do with it that's right
and that's what once broderick walks
away and spits on the ground that's
where i come make up inspector gadgets
cap and you put it on like shia labeouf
in the indiana jones the bad one that's
what you do and then and then harrison
ford stops you because even even even
spielberg i think was like
no
we don't do it we don't i don't like it
what's he going to do what's he going to
do yeah it would have been a more labor
move remember
a beefy moon pulling a buff
pulling a beast buff
balancing budgets and pulling beef buffs
beef booth if he picked up indiana
john's hat and just smelled it oh
instead of trying to put it on he just
went
and then it cuts to black executive
producer or do you do the slow motion
walk away like you smelled it
and then it it blows
the hat the hat glows
or do you cut the two wires on the hat i
don't know maybe i mean like a
levitation system yeah maybe i'm making
it too complicated i think we don't have
the budget for that i apologize
have you ever been brought in this is a
weird and random question
looking forward to
it yeah have you ever been brought into
the oakwood apartments to give a talk to
children about being in a sitcom i don't
know why i'm asking this it's based on
no data no research but you were on a
hit show tell me a weird time they were
like come explain hollywood to these out
of towners i can
[Music]
i can tell you
that
um anybody
whose marriage has ever been in trouble
ends up at the oakwood apartments have
you lived at the oakwood apartments yes
i did because you and i are both
divorced so you married an actor yeah
and then it went sideways it went
sideways i'd love to know why it went
sideways not for clickbait but because
it's interesting to me um what you
learned from that and then how you ended
up at the oak wood but let's let's start
there if you don't okay well i was
married uh for 14 years you met her on
the set of 30 rock yeah from the nbc
yeah that's right
and then um
yeah yeah that's right that's exactly
that's the name of the show 30 rock from
the nbc from the nbc with liz lemon
who's named liz lemon and uh
he shot somebody
oh
i apologize that's not i shouldn't have
unfortunately that was one of the if i
evolved i swear to god if i would have
had time to workshop that joke a little
bit yeah open mic more there's an open
mic podcast down the street that you can
try out your bets oh there's like 50.
and b
is that why you came here
what did you do we're lined with open
mic podcasts where you can try your
baldwin riff and then and then you kind
of and then you realize that you're like
oh i'm not gonna do that
but i mean when you're on the 30 rock
icon it does come to mind yeah that's
you're only being honest it crosses your
mind i did what i did and i but but but
at the same time i'm i'm uh i'm i'm
fully like
yes one of the things this show is
celebrating
is that raw this is gonna sound fake but
i mean it that raw
weird weird side of humanity yes you're
we're riffing maybe you say something
and you go i went a little squirrelly
that's life i don't want to
pre-interview you i don't want to let
you're not going to leno
i'd rather have footage that when we're
long dead they'll go there they are that
was them that was them that was them and
you know what awkward and all and that's
the best part is that i can look at you
and say you're a stone cold [__]
and it's fine it's it's like it's
acceptable it's like cold [__] you're a
stone cold [__] i could have taken a 45
minute break when you were like i could
look at you and say i'd go in the back
45 minutes i never would have guessed
that you were about to say
called [__] i didn't see it coming
either
tell me
i didn't think i i don't know my my uh
we're going to get a break technique
we're going to get to your comedy chops
because i'm such a fan you're so funny
but let's let's go where we are but we
sort of wrapped up the leno thing so i'm
going to say we're moving on
you met her on third rock from the sun
she did a guest star yeah is that
correct yeah
and then we entered into a
flirt immediately maybe that's
uncomfortable yeah no we didn't well she
she had been um
uh i talked to her last week we're still
like are you friends yeah can i do this
is this too like well for radio like a
thumb up in russia thumb up
that's right that's correct
yeah
well but she had been previously married
to dennis hopper
wow
and so what era hopper
uh she was the speed
yeah were they together during speed she
was well she was the uh what's the
basketball movie um the uh
hoop dreams
hoops
hoop nightmares you know i'm going to be
honest with you dennis hopper is one of
those guys yeah there's a lot of actors
where we're like oh my god dennis hopper
yeah they got him for that show and i'm
like this is the first thing i've kind
of seen
like you know they're legends but yeah
kind of like you haven't seen
a drugstore cowboy or something and
you're like no i haven't
seen it no no i haven't seen it yeah
yeah everybody makes you feel stupid
exactly yeah so she was married to a
water world water world hopper time
hopper okay so i just thought that like
his legend for misbehavior i thought
well
how bad can i be
is hopper legendary a misbehavior yes a
squirrely mm-hmm really
insane asylum
level like a nuts a lot of drugs a lot
of craziness lots of crazy
lots of grazo raisins and so i just
thought
what flavor crazy like like gary busey
like i watched a movie on my teeth last
night and then he does the scene yes
like just kind of nut so yeah
like beauty beauty level busy not uh
pervy
just kind of nutty no no but a little of
that yeah all of it beauty flavor
um i don't know what flavor that is is
that like grape
oh my god if you see gary busey drinking
a soda you know it's great i saw him at
bill maher's house one time
and he's no longer no but mar he's got
more yeah and he he waved at me and he
was on the opposite side of uh
like a very clean glass window
and then gary busey walked into it like
a bird
the sound of those male kira knightly
choppers banging into plate glass and
and bill mark comes out and goes new
rule don't put gary near the big window
yeah and meanwhile like uh
like
florence henderson is just hanging out
like from the brady bunch you're like
you know and she's talking to like the
the
like
like some porn star
it's just can i you know what you do if
that happens if i'm bill maher and would
you see smears my glass and there's just
like a you know kind of like a waxy
originally what's your reaction imprint
i save it like the shroud of turin is
what i do
i banksy that [__] i put plate glass
around it and i go would you like to see
my busy impressions then you just
replace the window oh my god of course i
go this is where busy waved at french
steward past the girl from brady bunch
talking to a porn star
and abusey you ever turn abusey because
that shit's worth 89 grand a minute you
start to wonder what was worth what like
at certain points of your life where
like yeah i could have i could have
turned a bucy you could have turned a
busy into a fat profit a fat profit i
mean just the absurdity oh that's our
new band fat profit yeah do you want to
what do you play bass i'll play anything
all right but not well but i'll play
bass i like that you guys basically
they did fine except except for they
died
um
i just can't
oh chili vanilla i love it i apologize
vanilla coke
that's my favorite drink that's the new
flavor yeah it's it's how many calories
so there's a zero yeah
there's a there's a ruse in there i'm
really
for those of you who aren't our age uh
millie vanilli yeah a lip syncing duet
would you call them a duet i would call
them a duet can you join me in this yes
do you remember the song yeah don't
forget
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought to us by our friends
at blue chew guys it is time to bring
that summer heat into the bedroom blue
chew is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets you take at a fraction of the
cost you can take them anytime day or
night so no need to plan ahead and you
can be ready whenever the opportunity
arises the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online so no more weird
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacies blue chews tablets are
made in the usa and are prepared and
shipped directly to your door in a
discrete package with blue chew men
everywhere excited to see the postman
because when your package has arrived
your package
has arrived so if you could benefit from
extra confidence when it's time to
perform blue chew can help and we've got
a special deal for weirdos try blue chew
free when you use promo code weird at
checkout pay just five dollars shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code weird to
receive your first month free visit
bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information and thank
you bluechu for sponsoring this podcast
weirdos i'm gonna be honest with you
sometimes when i'm online
uh i'd rather people not know what i'm
doing online
i wouldn't want a list of every website
i've ever been to this week
broadcast to the world and that is why
uh i like expressvpn i know what you're
probably thinking why don't you just use
incognito mode with the with the glasses
and the fedora let me tell you something
incognito mode does not hide your
activity it doesn't matter what mode you
use or how many times you clear your
browser history
filled with shame or not your internet
service provider can still see every
single website you've ever visited
that's some terrifying [__]
that's why whenever i'm home i never go
online without using
expressvpn it doesn't matter who your
internet service provider is ip isps in
the us can legally sell your information
to ad companies expressvpn is an app
that reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so your isp
can't see the sites you visit that's a
really great idea if you love privacy
like i do and if you love not having
apps track you like some dystopian
future nightmare expressvpn also keeps
all of your information secure by
encrypting 100 of your data with the
most powerful encryption available most
of the time i don't even realize i have
it on expressvpn is very very subtle it
runs seamlessly in the background and is
so easy to use all you have to do is tap
one button and boom you're protected
expressvpn is available on all your
devices phones computers even your smart
tv so there's no excuse for you to not
be using it protect your online identity
today with the vpn rated number one by
business insiders business insider
excuse me visit my exclusive link
expressvpn.com
weirdo and you can get an extra three
months free on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
weirdo
expressvpn.com weirdo to learn more
keep your stuff private and show your
support of this show
look
i've drunk
more times i don't know why you're doing
this to me i'm a nice
man you know i'm a nice man the only
reason that i'm here is that
you know my wife's best friend
is your makeup artist
she's that's her best friend that's my
wife's my wife has a shoddy group of
ladies yeah that she hangs out a murder
of ladies
now you've got a group of crows
of squirrely ladies a murder of
squirrely ladies well i love cat cat has
been we've been working together for
over a decade she's the best she's
wonderful
and she said french stewart and i said
wee-wee
oh we we because of your name oh
that's nice that makes you happy
because of steward
so that was a great gary busey story and
i loved it and we were talking about
your divorce so you were at that party
yeah it's good to get back to the
divorce yeah we want to get back to the
divorce that's where you want to go
that's what the people are well they
come for the silly riffs and then they
go
but where's the mate where's the divorce
mate where's the divorce mate oh that's
our other band kebabs are called yeah
that's correct no one doing well is
honking down on the street kebabs that
guy's going through a problem and he
might be living at the oak woods we're
getting there oh at the oakwood yeah
yeah but first you meet her how did we
get to that party oh um to the oakwood
party because we were talking about gary
bc and uh dennis hopper and that dennis
hopper is grape flavored they have taken
us off the trail and i brought us back
thanks we're in oregon baby oh so you
were like how nut oh
we're an oregon baby
you got it oh [__] you're on a black now
we're off the trail again yes because
dysentery
my daughter just had to do like a month
worth of uh personal diary of the oregon
trail she's eight
and they have to like
do a like
yeah the trail has been hard yeah the
wagon is broken she's an la girl and
there's no craft service and the air is
not being piped in between takes
you're like
we got to move to manhattan beach
and she's like she's like doing the
fastball down the middle she's doing um
it's cold you know where's the food yes
uh a broken wagon wheel and i'm trying
to after a month talk her into a little
cannibalism
like i'm trying to get a grizzly bear
attack out of this
and what the bear left behind the scraps
we made jerky out of we made a jerky out
of it
nigel nigel
it would be like
nigel nigel and fjorgan hung up strips
of papaya and it dried overnight that's
what if and we know but what i ended up
doing is i steered her in the wrong
direction and i said well you know she
said well if i'm gonna she was
considering it
and she said well if if we're gonna eat
somebody who do we eat little timmy and
i said no
you've got eight sisters little timmy's
not going to get you through a week
yeah why a sister get get a get a older
like yeah somebody older an uncle a big
fat can i say something that's never
been said before okay in a disaster
uncles are for eating
like but i'm not even kidding no you
can't eat your dad because you don't
like it you're not clear
right you gotta eat the uncle you sneak
up on him like a panther in the night
it's what he would have wanted is what
you say it's what he was cleaning for as
he's screaming i don't want this i don't
want this goat it's what he would have
wanted
i still want it so he's so kind uncle
jen and he fed us we didn't even wait
for him to die no we didn't wait we
can't wait we're starving no hey
look we want to be considerate about it
we don't want to just knock his
well you could knock him unconscious
that's a courtesy
is that yeah but but the problem is is
that i think that she was going back and
forth between um cannibalism
and like like how would he die
like was it and i said well it could be
exposure you know
he could just die in the in the snow
yeah and then she said
okay
um we could do it that way and i said
well what's his name and she said uncle
buck
john candy so this is a big meal so now
i'm thinking about defrosting john candy
which is going to take a really long
time i want to say talk about my alec
baldwin moment i didn't mean to make a
john candy's like a big guy joke but i
did you did it i didn't guess what now
you're off the air
off canadian you're off canadian
television now officially officially
done with no vancouver
piss off vancouver can i just say the
one place where you speak frankly about
two places
about body weight body mass index all
that stuff one the doctor yes you're
just gonna talk about like this is how
much you weigh you have to do it and
you're soft or you're big or you're this
or you're muscly or whatever right your
blood pressure whatever it's honest time
to
in a situation where people are going to
get eaten
nobody's going like
john kenny you see you you said
kind-faced
uh brown hair
if you're gonna if you're looking to eat
you go he's a bigger guy
and that's number one on the agenda i
have to say like but how do you prepare
him
his name's candy
so you
you caramelize him like what
come on
like no you've got to put him on a spit
and turn him around for like a really
long time but you don't let the kids see
that and then when you serve them you
say we caramelize no the kids go go and
see a pioneer movie they go watch a
movie as was the way uh
pioneers where they had electricity and
movies grab an ipad get in the covered
wagon i'm probably in that movie because
it's a reboot and it's a shoot
broderick's not in it french stewart's
going to be playing i'm replacing yeah
that's what your business card does
french stewart i'm replacing i'm
replacing oh i should just put that on
my i would love it right and i would
laugh can i ask you a real cannibal
question sure
you hear the stories like alive plane
crash you eat the dead people yes
are there or really have you heard of
stories
where me you and katie are in a cabin
and it's going goofy and we're gonna die
okay you have to murder someone yeah
like murder cannibal is totally
different from well we have these bodies
right you know what i'm saying yeah we
have these bodies everyone's like well
they had the bodies
yeah and you look the other way no
you're like we have to get a rock we
have to make a decision
it's like we have to draw straws drawing
stress is only for kid parties or the
worst day of your life if you notice
that's right but what you do is you look
at you know you know how like you're you
you have let's say you have three people
you me katie yeah uh let's just say what
we're all thinking you're eating me
like i'm i'm getting to that
[Laughter]
you know how like there's like certain
people in a group where you you they're
the one who take the picture
they're the ones they're not they're not
the good enough one to be in the picture
and so they're the edible one i'm gonna
give you a daytime emmy award for that
observation oh a daytime do you want you
break up do i have to go you don't have
to go satellite pre-tape uh oh like a
zoom thing yeah like if you want a bafta
oh well or you can go if you want like
you're this is your agent trying to take
it off
okay you can go yeah i wanna i'm gonna
hang out with uh uh you know people from
ice
yeah or or uh from soap operas so purple
stuff oh yeah i was going to bafta's
you're saying daytime mommy i'm i'm
going with full date yeah i'm going to
tt look at me
i mean you're filling in for someone
yeah your observation is as good as gold
the person who takes the picture
is the person
i mean
as a stand-up i feel very confident that
we've inadvertently written a routine
that will only exist here right that
drawing straws is either at a kid's
birthday party or the worst day of your
life yeah and you know who you eat it's
the person who takes it who takes the
picture you can have it i want you to
have it you want should i try it yes
deal
you'll do it and i'll send it i'll try
it i'll text you the audio of it oh i
would like that
i would really like that because we got
it is that you would think that it's
like i'm writing it down that katie was
taking the picture because we're
you know we're doing the show but yeah i
i
i don't know i like katie and i think
you have to take the picture and then oh
my god and then me and katie uh well but
also big just because you're so big
like you're you're tall and you're no no
you're a
this is my jesus moment jesus christ
yeah this is my oh this is like it's a
good death we're going to die yeah
not today you're not you're going to
have a pizza cue
yeah you're going to you're gonna john
carmelize my candy ass yeah i'm gonna
yeah and then but and then eventually
how do i end like just
a standard old heart attack well the
joke my revenge is you choke on me as
you're eating my love handle you choke
and you swear you hear my essence going
suck it you what did you call me
some kind of [__]
oh yeah i can't remember what kind of
[__] i referred to you as
so as you're trying to eat me i you hear
suck at you stone cold [__] and then
you die and then katie it's both of us
and then five minutes later rescue comes
and she realizes she didn't have to eat
that no that's not what happened oh tell
me what happens is i choke on you and
then katie heimlich me
and then we we just like fall in love
that's exactly what happened like that's
what and then we just like off to vegas
for a quick tasty wedding yeah like a j
like oh no we go to city hall like a
couple of old pioneer people on the
oregon
trail oregon oregon brought it back you
really did and you were back at divorce
skanky [__] she's scared now i'm scary
well i don't know why like i i just
couldn't remember what the original lego
is stone cold we can play the table oh
so-called
okay let's go let's stick with that so
you met her she was d she had she was
already divorced yes from dennis hopper
who was nutso yes and is that maybe we
don't know
uh dead he dead he did okay then i don't
feel so bad about the fact that we're
being like he was insane because
you know i don't want dennis hopper
after me with his with his mangled hand
from speed no you wouldn't he's not like
his lack of faith from water world yeah
yeah he always they were always like
mangle that thing was always something
mangle him up mangle him up but it
wasn't film him i'm also picturing
uh
anthony hopkins i realize yes when you
say dennis hopper i go same smell
i don't know what that means i'm sorry
but you've won another daytime emmy two
daytime emmys just right now one of them
is not just nominated can i just say if
you're in a pitch black room yeah dennis
hopper is there living right
uh and
what's his name what's the other guy
anthony anthony hopkins is there but
it's pitch black both living both are
living and fine
and had time to prepare yes they dressed
themselves they made themselves whatever
they knew they did whatever they do and
you go around sniffing you can't tell
you can't that is the same yeah if if
you had to if if getting out of that
room was a matter of uh discerning their
smells buy smell you won't be able to do
you won't be able to you should just say
just end me now and you know what i'm
done eat me
uh see on the oregon trail she had been
married so
was she
i don't know why i'm asking your age but
we were
i was picturing a younger woman we're
let me see
because you're about like five years off
or something okay okay like normal so
here comes a nice normal and she comes
in and she's been married to dennis
hopper and you know this yes and you're
like i'm going to be nuts
well
no
no like in a frenchy way not in a in a
hoppy way well it would no it was just
it just felt like uh
well how bad can i be
yeah and so it
i guess it
yeah you're right it loosened it up a
little bit yeah you were and and you
kind of had a crush from the moment you
saw
you were like i'm in yeah can i can i
offer this
i wish you would i wish it would can i
say yes when you're on set like when i
met you we were on set yeah that's a
great you
you know what i mean yeah it's an open
you yeah all the fight flight mechanisms
are down you've been taken care of yes
someone has dressed you it's awesome
they've made my face look it's better
than it is exactly they put like someone
like cat makes you look fantastic and
you're a little on point like you're a
better you yeah that's right and
you're you know
you're okay you feel safe so what i'm
saying is your heart tends to be open
you're performing so you're loosened up
yeah it's a great place uh to
potentially meet somebody conan o'brien
met his wife
and you're an active you you're an
active you like this podcast the best
version of me is really right best buy
then you're gonna be garbage that's what
i mean yeah smoking camels yeah smoking
coffee eating
yeah like a drama dairy camel but
no
yes
val and i do this podcast once a week
just she and i fantastic because we get
a little bit of the
onset flavor in our relationship so i'm
just trying to set the stage you you see
from across the set you're like what
season are we in of 30 rock
oh
uh it was it was like the second episode
of so i was fresh as a daisy okay i like
that even more i was i was bony and
skinny and sexy
and so i was just right there i was
right in my wheelhouse i love that you
were like it was bony and skinny and
disgusting and so sexy
yeah yeah yeah yeah i didn't think boney
boney doesn't usually proceed sexy like
you're like i was bony and young and i
never looked better like yeah that's
yeah i don't even know been trying to
get back that level
a little bit better too we'll send you
to you made it straight i appreciate it
so you but that but then my my like then
i got married to vanessa i've been
married to vanessa for
12 years well it'll be our 11th
anniversary
in a week no way and i met her
doing a play she was doing a play at the
geffen i was doing a play at the other
theater in the geffen and it was a green
room romance and so again like it's the
freshened up version of yourself the
open-hearted yeah can i
where are you don't let me sorry to
interrupt you you were saying you where
are you where are you where are you
green room romance where you
where is
i would go in and make a bunch of dumb
jokes
and i would i would tell her what our
date was gonna be
and it was basically always a horrible
date like where okay i'm gonna pick you
up at six in the morning
and then we're driving you know we're
driving to fontana uh we're gonna see
some dirt bike shows and then you know
we're gonna uh
you know we're gonna eat peeps what a
great meat cute you really pitched a
terrible date and you did it
consistently over and over and over
again and you wore her heart
open but i wore her heart open oh oh
oh i love that yeah you i wore her heart
open the name of your book that you guys
write together i wore her heart open i
wore her heart open yeah i snuck up on
her like a panther in the night
like
but i have to do that because i can't
i'm not good at dating yes
i'm not good at like a it feels like an
audition i can't do it it's so great
but it's it's a job interview where
there's a potential that one of you ends
up naked that's exactly right and it's
very awkward i i i made 30 days similar
in tone where i'm like i love being
married because i hate dating like
what's worse than just being like
what harry potter character are you like
kill yourself it's the worst thing
that's the worst thing you can get
married get intimate get close that's
the thing oh yeah and then just drive it
then just drive it baby drive it like a
rental car that's right well not
recklessly
you got the insurance you can trade it
in for another pt cruiser and i did
dang it can i ask you this sure b i'm
going to project me on to you but
hopefully you like great
the reason why set pete
is the openhearted it's where i make
friends it's it's it's just like what
we're saying why i'm not surprised you
met both of your partners in showbiz
settings right is it because like me
i find the unstructured chaos world of
just random barbecues in staten island
yes to be so overwhelming that i tend to
shut down yes
hit it tell me everything that's that's
the deal i'm i'm uh
i'm but the thing about me is that i i'm
a i'm a sprinter i can um
i can do like uh
i can do a period of being with people
yes but also largely i'm insular yes and
so i uh
uh you know my my wife says like i'm i'm
like uh what is it like the kid from
stranger
what is it like stranger things yeah
from stranger things where 11 i'm 11.
yeah where i'll sprint for a while and
then i bleed from the nose
that is a great it really is like
it's incredibly similar are you yes what
do you do like do you do you just like
you can you can have a burst bursts of
being with people and i'm not cracking
everybody up and then suddenly she has
liquid
yes yeah i'll go in and razzle dazzle
and then like that's me i don't think
this was mean but i would when we did
how we roll yeah
i would i would eat lunch by myself i
liked eating yes by myself i like to eat
my i don't want to eat lunch with people
thank you because i felt a little weird
saying that but it was because i want to
meditate i want to rest i want to eat i
want to just recharge yeah oh you're
you're on set with these people all day
and they're your friends and you're
happy but you get that it's an hour yeah
or maybe 45 minutes you're like
oh i just want to be still quiet yeah
quiet recharge plug in the electric car
baby because the thing is is that
they're your they're your friends it's
not like
you know it's not like you see you know
chai mcbride coming and you're all like
oh god you know it's like you love it
but it's elevated it's an elevated sense
of being with people it's not
it's not normal can i say the funniest
thing about stranger things now i wish
you would strangers stranger things
season four the scariest part is it's
the awkward year
like the horror
is just what it's like to go through
puberty in front of a camera that's
exactly that's the the monster in season
four is but the worst
i swear i connect to that more than
anything because but but it's largely
because i'm i'm i'm also uh you know i'm
58 now but
i
yeah you're one of those tea cruise
[__] yeah i'm hot as [__]
bony and you're sexy i'm bony i wouldn't
have thought you were i mean we live in
this town where we just constantly blow
smoke but i'm like i i said earlier if
you're not our age yeah
no but but that's the thing is that i
still look great in my heart yes feel
like a seventh grade boy who's going to
middle school and i think a lot of
comedians and
comedic actors feel that way where they
just
they're all and that's why they're both
wonderful and terrible
i completely agree yeah and when things
go bad if i have a bad set a bad day
whatever it might be if that's the fear
body or whatever you want to call it is
my awkward wet rayon shirt clammy hand
ruddy cheek
braces boy
and i go they know they know and then
when i'm on set and i'm like everyone
here seems to think i'm a man
yeah i love it isn't it wonderful i'm
eating a sandwich and i'm pretending
to be grown and together and shiny yes
and as soon as i you know something goes
squirrelly which it does
you go everyone knows that in junior
high i was the kid that didn't get
invited to the party yes and now
everyone knows i'm still that you relate
to that yes nobody's picking me for
kickball yes and i'm just gonna uh
i'm just gonna sit here with my acne yep
and and a little bit of acne right a
little bit of back name a little
background a little buttony
i can't figure out how not to smell bad
because there's no like spray because
it's the 70s
buddy
if you saw me in junior high yeah the
amount of primping i did yes
any we we're like post therapy now like
you do you have kids yeah i've got i've
got a eight-year-old daughter so we both
have one daughter as well so now we have
kids and we're post therapy parents like
we kind of like yes we just the internet
television i don't know what it is but
we all know way more than we used to
know yes and if you if parents from
these days or just uh teachers from this
day they would be like
why is pete
like
burning off everything with astringent
then putting on like all these smells
and oils why is this [__] child
wearing cologne yes here's the answer
and by the way i don't mean to put the
onus on them
uh i'm telling you that i'm like
something's wrong with how i am so i
must put on every item from cvs yeah so
no one smells the real me yes no one
sees the real hair that's the one
yes it's the armor i thought if i could
if i could feather my hair
and be in a leisure suit yes
and
if i can skate backwards
all the ladies will somehow now love me
that's right all the boys will want to
be you and all the girls will uh want to
be with you but i'm not
you know but i'm king of the nerds of
course that's what ended up that that is
what's been interesting to me the past
couple weeks especially is just like is
what's right under the surface of you
and i and what can be kind of strange
and risky about this business
is when you when you are like at a peak
yeah it's very tempting to believe it
would you talk a little bit about that
like believe the hype
yes i i you were on a hitch i'm not by
the way yeah you're beloved you're great
i think you're fantastic and there was a
time when
my mom would have been like screaming to
see you and stuff you know what i'm
saying i'm sure you get that still
sometime i'm talking about those peak
moments the temptation to be like
i
am like a living god yeah that's what
that's what they're screaming crowds and
the late night and the money well you're
like and you're walking through like
disneyland and people are just giving
you free things that's right and you you
you start to they take you to the front
of line yeah they take you to the
frontal line i think the problem was is
that i was like i you know you would get
basketball tickets and things like that
and
but at the same time
i i just i didn't believe it i'm glad
you feel like a guy who didn't believe
it because if you did believe it but i
don't know if i didn't believe it in a
like a bad way like a low self
self-esteem no that's what i mean yeah i
didn't hear you that way i heard you
going
careful frenchie you call yourself
frenchie careful frenchie oh i like it
i wonder if i is it because you did so
much theater before you broke into tv
what grounded you
because
you know living in this town you do see
people believe their own hype and if you
live by it you also die by it i i i
always like i got this uh advice from uh
like an old actor just saying take the
best job
not him yeah do a bunch of drugs do a
bunch of drugs
oh no
no it was like it was just he said just
take the best like job in front of you
and so that's what i've always done and
if it's like
if it's something really good that's
great and if it's some weird children's
show that's fine like but i'm just very
pragmatic you know who else said that to
me who paul bettany oh really and i was
like you have this interesting career
like you did this and all these art
house films and then you were an avenger
and he's like i don't know i don't know
where people get this idea that's not
even the right accent that that i'm out
there no i like it curating i'll keep
doing it curate in me career career he's
a cockney he's not he doesn't even say
pool pool betany
pool hey paul hey p-o-o-h
lanky [__] you lanky [__] i'm not
avenger
i'm vision vision's not in the team he
oversees it i'm actually really liking
your paul benny this is a great paul
batney
hey i'm married to jennifer cornerly
cornelia
and she was in top gun she replaced the
woman who aged [__] golf remember oh
wait she's not playing that woman but
val and i saw top gun and we were like
is she supposed to be the woman from the
first one no that's not can't figure it
out
you were saying take the best job paul
benny agrees with you yeah just be
pragmatic and you know a lot of times
it's just about putting braces on a kid
or yeah or
like if you if you're lucky enough to
have a pool about you know cleaning it
or cleaning your pool or getting a pool
or getting a pool yeah yeah anything or
lowering your anxiety stroke yeah
like when i had my um
i i had a fancy house
uh
up on doheny in west hollywood and i
lived across from uh halle berry
and i remember thinking like oh that
house caused me more stress
just because it was the the amount of
money to maintain it
and the amount of
just effort to get a job or go do a
hallmark movie so i could keep that
house oh you meant your house i thought
you meant looking at halle berry's house
she lived across the which i'm assuming
was covered in berry bushes
holly holly climbing up the side and
raspberries blueberries strawberries but
like one day what happened was like the
you know the uh tour buses that come by
and they're like oh and that's halle
berry's house and blah blah blah blah
and that's winona ryder's house well and
i remember i was coming out and i was
just taking my trash out
and i was wearing shorts and a cigarette
yeah yeah i'm just smoking cigarettes no
joseph gordon questions yeah and i come
out in the
like yeah the the uh tour guide goes oh
and there's french stewart and there was
a woman there with a camera and she went
oh
like she was very disappointed by me
need that story yeah framed in my
bathroom so i see it every day right she
because
she was just like she dropped her camera
i couldn't be more disappointed and i
just remember thinking like
[__] man
i but i feel like it ties into you
saying it sounds like we get rid of this
house and it sounds like you were
learning the lesson that you now know
which is like really don't believe it oh
because even when you're
living across from halle berry and the
show's on yeah it's still you can't
tie your sense of value to whether or
not a woman takes your picture or not
yeah and it sounds like you already knew
that but you saw it and you feel it the
universe was gonna say something nuts
kind enough to be cruel to you in that
moment yes to go like don't forget don't
forget don't forget it's true right it
really is it's like it's a weird
reminder
i mean i remember like i love that story
i hate it and i love it it i hate it and
love it too yes yes keep going but like
but it was uh you know there was a
moment with my wife where we got into uh
um
a big argument and this was like what
almost ended it but it was this is
number one
this is number one the first mrs stewart
how about that fun
and
basically like
we had this place in lake tahoe
and so i drove up to lake tahoe and i
was just very mad at her
and
i sat down in a casino
and i was like
you know i'm not even religious but i'm
like god i need a sign
i need to know what to do i like i i
need some sort of sign
like if i should leave or if i should
stay
i play a hand of
poker
on a machine
and i instantly hit a royal flash
and i make
like two thousand five hundred dollars
just bang
whoa there's my there's my sign
and so then i'm interesting because i'm
like is that a sign to leave or assigned
to stay it's that's something i stayed
for like another seven years because of
the royal flush
i i did i wasn't specific about the sign
that's the problem you have to say if
you got to say
if i should leave should i stay or
should i go now
to quote the clash yeah and if you go
there will be trouble but if you still
double so you should go you should go
yeah that's that's better if you go it
should be trouble that's literally half
if you stay it'll be double so don't
stay i doubled it
i clash doubled it
can i just say by the way i've had
moments in relationships that were like
and i wonder you don't have to share
this i'm sharing this i've been in
relationships where i'm like this is
wrong
but often the wrong ones have these high
highs yeah that's
really low lows like the worst like
like i was almost 300 pounds drinking
constantly smoking cigarettes just like
a mess yeah and then we'd have like the
best day of our lives like absolute i'm
saying the relationship itself had
borderline personalities no no that's
absolutely right but that's the thing
that like but i wouldn't be like i'm out
and then some weird yeah i would have
and i'd stay another year or something
like yeah and you're like what am i
doing yeah what am i this like
like my wife now like vanessa we've been
together again like it'll be 11 years 11
years
and she uh
we're very even and we're very
frenchie i think the thing that i
learned in the first relationship is to
just be careful with your words
because you say something to somebody
that you can't take back
and it just sits in their heart
like a a
awful explosion
and it just comes up over and over again
and so i just try to be really
and we're just very gentle and my kid is
like very easy
i don't have to do anything other than
just not mess her up mm-hmm
you know
i was but i was lucky because i was 50
when she was born i had one sperm left
and he dog paddled his way to victory
on a boogie board on a boogie board he
needed oh he needed plenty of help yeah
and you had to if i may you had to go
after the phone oh yeah just a little
wind oh yeah a little bit of wind uh
maybe like uh a tiger joint
yeah he needed a little boat that was
inserted this is a medical procedure
that's right a tiny tiny tiny tug but
for one sperm
you're one
and remaining sperm
just fell into an egg yeah he tripped it
was mostly to rest
he's like that looks like it's really
safe it was more about sleep yeah he
didn't want to make a baby no he didn't
and you had a baby when you were 50 how
about that i love it and i need it yeah
i tell i always uh tell my wife like
look uh uh i can't get her through
college and then everything else is just
a problem for her stepfather
you are a living
legend can i go back one click i will i
want to get to your daughter for sure
that's such a beautiful thing
what are what are
talk about those words that's great
advice the reason i like talking about
divorces is because like you i'm
divorced and now i'm in i'd use the same
words even
safe yeah gentle it's she's my greatest
adventure too but it's not because we're
having huge fights and then making up
it's not this no it's like it's like
this it's like we have like yeah just we
have novelty and then we have normal
weeks and then we have novelty and we
have normal that's exactly right that's
it special weird times and then just a
lot of ordinary time yeah like like we
just like a lot of it is i mean we can
we can sit in a room together and not
talk
yes like can be you know just just still
or quiet in a space together yes
but it's also
she's very uh
i think she really understands me and
she is uh she gets mad maybe twice a
year and then you know i'm going to
tiffany's because she's she's right
she's just right you know and she's very
gentle going to halle berry's house i'm
picking straubs blubs straws and blooms
and a little bit of that holly and i'm
gonna yeah yeah flip off my old berry
wait for the tmz bus say i'm french
stewart [__] get your film out
yeah get your camera out get your cam i
want i'm gonna photos i'm gonna do two
different looks
i'm gonna i'm gonna change clothes you
can just keep this idling
here's why i'm asking this question
because people say things that live in
your heart that was like poetry what you
said
and and like a terrible explosion yes
what is something that just like
burrowed in your heart that bothered you
or something you said because the people
that are saying things like this it
doesn't have to be exactly but the
people that are saying things like this
probably don't know
what it sounds like when you're saying
something that might have just [__] up
somebody's life yeah i i had an agent
who um said we need to redo your photos
and i said oh
okay
why and he said well
your head looks like a potato
and your nose looks like a smaller
potato that was stapled onto the larger
potato
and now agent don rickles
what is happening no i know and now i i
can't like i can't unsee it like every
time i look in the mirror like yeah it
kind of french can i say something yeah
it does right no
no [__]
no let's let's print out that joke a
hundred thousand times and make a big
bonfire out of it okay because it's only
true in the sense that that's true of
everybody
everybody's head looks like a [__]
potato with a potato staple to it i
guess that's true it's the whole concept
of mr potato and one of the biggest toys
of all time
people playing with potatoes before mr
potato head yeah the potato for its
human head like qualities yeah yeah and
they weren't like this looks like a
freak they were like this looks like a
human head this is a human head potato
is normal in fact you go to the doctor
and you're like i'm worried about the
shape of my head they go what are you
talking about you got a perfect potato
that's the clinical term
so who's your agent what agency uta wme
i can't remember who it was that did it
it was like a small agent but i just
remember thinking like
[__] okay yeah that'll be that's a
terrible explosion but now like but it's
the same thing i like uh
i got kicked out of disneyland
for smoking pot on the people mover and
it used to be a thing where it was just
it was like a train
it was a tram
and that's i've been like
yeah and i got off of the people mover
and then there were two bobbies
like this was back in the 80s when they
were like
dressed yeah hello gardner i understand
you're having a bit of the wacky tobacco
yeah come with me mate smoking something
yeah go on so they take me to uh uh
disney jail
which is where goofy is most of them
it's mostly just goofy because goofy
can't stop being goofy it's his name
it's just pushing kids by the face yeah
yeah with that huge puffy white hand he
pushes him yeah he just pushes him he
doesn't understand his strength
they go flying yeah they go flying
and he's like
no you know what disney jail is pirates
of the caribbean
and you have to be beckoning the dog
with the key
oh that's with the bone oh that's where
they should put people and then on the
ride you're shamed they go there's
johnny depp there's [__] there's uh the
real life friend stuart there's a woman
on the boat she goes
oh
and it's not because they don't allow
photographs because she's deeply
disappointed it's a sadness it's just
and then she takes a picture of the
animatronic johnny depp she's like this
is worth it
not that that would be a good disney
deal but what is real disney jail
uh it was a it seemed like somebody's
like a lunch break room sure where they
just sat me down and then they told me
um they showed me a picture of me
smoking pot on the people mover and i
was like okay all right i got it did the
picture you have like a cartoon border
that said like you can fly no it was
more like it was like an impact it was
more prison like a rabbit
it was a bad photo it was like going
through a red light no it wasn't like
when you're coming off the ride and
you're like whoa
oh my god they we use that we actually
use the uh the log flume technology to
capture this photo of you how great
would that be oh now i just want to
restructure their jail system
we could do it we could do it were there
children around frenchie um
i don't think so i don't remember it
yeah you bro i mean most people
they're going to go to the beginning
they told me like when they let me go
they sat me down for like an hour and
then they let me go and they said
never come back
they said yeah
the disney people said never come back
and so now
still when i take my daughter to
disneyland
oh yeah i'm still a little bit like
you're on the lookout i'm on the like it
hits me i'm like do they have like
there's gonna be a guy swinging an ncis
photo that like shows me like 30 years
ago even if they did they'd be like well
clearly this is a joke this is french
stewart that's that's just like an
example of what a picture might be
yeah this potato guy can't come here but
i know
mr potato face
oh no potato but it's still like i think
i'm such a rule follower buddy that i
still sort of
i don't know i'm not gonna look i i want
to join you in my rule bre in your rule
breaking in the most wonderful place
magical place happiest place it's the
happiest place on earth i did a gig i'm
gonna tell the story 30 seconds i did a
gig for disney and it was great it was
like a corporate show at disney world
and afterwards they were like you can go
to any park you want but after the show
the only one that's open is epcot
because one park stays open until
midnight
so i finish the show i go up to the
ticket booth it's closed i think
wait what is this and they're like oh
the the park is open until 12 but the
ticket booth closes at seven and i'm
like but i
like what i love disney so much one of
the main reasons i did the gig was to go
to the park to the park and i had my my
friend with me that was like the the
escort is like a comedy central show my
friend from comedy central was there and
i was like but we want to go into epcot
so we go
to have you heard the story
maybe i've never told it before
that's impossible but i can't think of
when i told it anyway we go up to the
gate and you know how they have the tags
that say like kim and it says like
bloomington indiana like where they're
from right she's got to be 17. she
really looks super super young and i
just i'm like i'm going to jay holmes
this stuff that's my dad i'm like i'm
gonna talk my way into epcot i'm like
hello i'm only here for one night i just
did a show they told me i could go into
the park but i didn't go to the ticket
booth in time would you please just let
us in because it's not like the people
with tickets wear like sparkly caps and
everyone knows just let me in
like
i'm thinking like you do me what is the
policy in a place where everything
screams yes you can have whatever you
want we just want you to be happy yeah
magical disney like mickey mouse owns
this place please just be happy here i'm
like if i just do an earnest plea
clearly she'll let me in because you're
a good you're jimmy stewart you're a
good man
i did a stand-up comedy shot i just did
a show
i just had a show for the love of god
please
my ticket's not here it's in judy's
house it's in jimmy's house
please let me and and this young woman
doing her job i'm not mad at this woman
she goes i can't i can't let you in
without a ticket yeah and i'm like
again i'm getting into epcot like it's
gonna happen i don't mean i'm gonna
bully my way and i'm just like i
understand like a salesman i'm like i
understand you don't want my knives you
don't want this set of knives what if i
told you they can cut a penny like i'm
not i'm not going to stop the set yeah
yeah so i do it again i'm like i'm
telling you please ask anyone from my
heart from my heart i did the show
you're not going to get in trouble they
told me i could go in the park
please and she's like again i just can't
then she opens the gate because it's a
turn style to get in and that's where
you have to scan a ticket on she opens
the gate for a woman pushing a stroller
so and i start walking behind the woman
with the stroller sure and i look the
woman the young kimmy from bloomington
indiana in the eye and i i beckon my my
uh my friend to come with me i go kimmy
i'm gonna walk through the gate now
and if anyone stops me i'm going to tell
them that you told me i couldn't and
that you tried to stop me but then i
just ran through like so you're in the
clear you're in the clear you're in the
clinic i'm telling you if anyone stops
you can go back to bloomington you'll go
back tomorrow and you'll be employee of
the month because i could tell she
wanted to let me through she wanted to
but she couldn't figure out the avenue
to get you there was no verbal way to do
it it was like a forgiveness rather than
permission i was looking for permission
i was like please forgive me i said that
i was like i'm sorry just start drifting
through and what's happening kimmy
like you exactly and we crossed this
huge bridge and i the whole time i'm
waiting for a hand on my shoulder i'm
waiting for goofy to be like
exactly
and it's epcot so once you cross over
you're in japan and i literally felt
like we had left the country yeah that
was like we're safe now oh it's it's
night express
because of the rule breaking element and
of course we never got caught how are
you going to get caught
and kimmy of course never got in trouble
nobody knew nobody know nobody knew but
it was it made the night even better
yeah so i wonder if your trips to disney
now are a little bit richer because
you're like it's a little bit better
because it's it's like it's a good st oh
i've got a oh i've got a story i was
doing a movie for disney and it was a
children's movie and i'm not going to
say what it was but um i was doing a lot
of my own stunts back then live action
yes
and you know there's always a precocious
red-headed kid pushing you out of
treehouse or whatever it's like a kid's
movie yeah and so
they were like hey we want to we want to
give you a massage like we want to offer
you a massage and i said okay
and and they said just go anywhere and
just send us the bill
and so i was in new orleans and so i go
to this place i'm just like it's blocks
away i walked through the door and
suddenly i was like wow this is a lot of
red velvet like this is like i'm not
sure if there's a massage massage and i
get up there
and suddenly you know i'm like uh the
woman is like giving me this really
perfunctory massage
and then she's like
do you want to you want to flip over i
was in i had a very similar experience
my girlfriend at the time and i ate a
space cake in amsterdam
and if you don't know what a space cake
is usually we would split one space cake
is a very very strong weed edible yeah
this is like 20 years i've never done
well with edibles like they always these
are the edibles i can't judge them this
is the edible when people are like you
know you can't really judge an edible
they mean space cakes in amsterdam it's
like tourist trap yeah nightmare i don't
know if it's hash it's like you're gonna
go crazy as [__] and we've been smoking
pot and eating pot every day in
amsterdam yeah and after after a while
when you're doing at least when i'm
doing it every day like that when i was
a young man you almost stopped noticing
you just kind of like now you're just in
a museum
looking at a van gogh you know yeah
exactly you're all high like checking
out where anne frank was hiding yeah
that's also not a fun hydrant
i really did not enjoy that at all
so the last that comes out your eye
sure for sure
when you we ate the whole space cake
yeah on our last day and stoned out of
our minds just like you i we were like
let's get a massage
me and my girlfriend so this wasn't like
a gentleman of the night looking for
foul play it wasn't shady it wasn't
shady at all the first place we found
what brought it to mine was i was like
this is a lot of red velvet
but there were signs everywhere that
said massage only no sex and i was like
it's amsterdam prostitution is legal
like sex work is legal yeah they're like
in windows so you can exactly like gary
busey like gary exactly like gary buscey
who doesn't want that there's a bucy on
every third window in the red light
and then it becomes the the one everyone
wants to see um
so
i'm like if i'm very high very high like
out of my body high but i'm like if it
was a sex place it would say massage and
sex
like it's not right new york city where
they're going to be like kind of like
it's it seems specifically like they
were saying there was not so there's no
sex so we go in my girlfriend goes with
one person i go with another person she
says take off all your clothes
at this point i've had more massages now
so i know that's normal but that was
really weird to me at the time right i
was like because i'm still kind of
worried that it's sex yeah i take off
all my clothes uh because she really
insisted i was like i i left my
underwear on she came in and she said
all your clothes and i was like ah like
i went how european
yeah you just think you're on a nude
beach in
in france precisely yeah i'm going full
france but i'm down i'm i'm i'm business
down so she's just getting the hams and
she puts she puts a blanket over the
hands
and then she gives me a massage that was
so bad that's when i knew it that's how
you know
a perfunctory massage that's what also
brought that she's i mean it was
horrible terrible you know how when even
an amateur just kind of rubs your
shoulders you're like oh thank you this
was a nightmare this was like this is
the part before i get to the action
before i think it was a [__] palace
that's why i think the signs had no sex
it was like no sex just hand jobs but
i'm like that's still a sexual act yes
and it's amsterdam just put on the thing
no sex
parentheses except hand jobs except like
that's what we're about right you could
call the place hand job power hand job
palace yes seven dollars a hand job
you could call it that that's the whole
point but they're still being kind of
like so anyway well maybe like handy
mountain
you know what i mean like like give it a
john handy john handy a john handy
callback wow and then we just come a
jackhammer
oh a jacket deep thoughts deep thoughts
so she at one point i remember she goes
pete she asked my name and i was like
why does she want to she's saying my
name and i'm like i said pete and
immediately i was like
why did i tell her my real name if there
was any time to be skipped mcgavin
it was this moment but i go if there was
ever time to be darth mcfunksentin
i'm so stoned and so nervous yeah i just
go pete like i'm this person's bossing
me around basically take off all your
calls what's your name pete and then she
at one point kind of implies for my area
and she goes pete and i go no no no no
no no no no not for pete not for beep
uh i just the massage and she goes
really and i go yeah really and she's
just baffled by your lack of interest
i'm telling you i used to tell the story
on stage i was like that's probably the
weirdest thing she's ever seen as
somebody that was like i'm just here for
stress management i literally just my
muscles yeah just my muscles hurt and
then
what happened after i said no several
times
she just goes okay
and then goes back
french to the worst to the worst massage
of my life yeah at one point she sat me
up it's cold in the room by the way i'm
cold and she cracks my neck
i'm like this woman is obviously not
licensed in massage now she's just
dabbling in chiropractic
i'm like i think i just got injured
babbling and chiropractic i can't feel
my feet yes now i have no sensation in
this foot since that day the whole time
like i just wasn't a grown-up yet at
this time i'm like 28 years old and i'm
like i wasn't a grown-up i could have
just said like there's been a
misunderstanding i'll still pay but i'd
like to leave but i didn't want to
embarrass anyone yeah so i was looking
for a way to go like to leave yes and
then finally she says are you cold
because i was like probably looked cold
and i was like that's it i'm cold i'd
like to go she said oh no what about
your bath and i'm like i'm not staying
to find out about my bath
what's gonna go down there like what's
happening like in the bath
no bath
is it water is it lube i don't want a
bath sarah but what about your special
outfit
like wait what no no outfit and
at this point again i've told this story
on stage but like i was like i need to
get out of here who knows what's
happening to my girlfriend like i didn't
know is she oh yeah it's a double it's a
double concern at this point i was still
pretty religious and was like
not i wasn't gonna be like not into it
hey what did he do that sounds groovy
like i was like we got we both have to
get out of here and i have to like
rescue both i have to rescue both of us
i left and i go
uh she she tried to start this thing
even though all the signs said no sex i
were like what did you do and she just
went it was the best massage in my life
she just got a great massage
like a fantastic
non-erotic
by the way
that she was the only woman in the place
that's for [__] sure
no there were no women in the that's the
first thing are there other women in the
waiting room no if it's a lot of guys
like scratch and then kind of you know
what i mean get out of there that is
like
that's insane like like but that but the
other thing about a massage is that
i'm good for about like
10 minutes that's all you want
and then i don't want anymore
i just want you you would have loved
this massage
okay
tell me i i'm very that is an
interesting factoid i actually kind of
feel bad that you don't love massage
because i it's like one of my favorite
it's one of your favorite things in the
world yeah it's just not for me like i
like i like a little bit like i like a
uh uh to go to a chiropractor and like
get a back crack is that right yeah but
yeah
he gets mad at me because like like what
he does is he puts on the electricity
and then he and then he yeah and then he
leaves and he says i'll be back in a
minute
and then i always reach over and i crank
it up like a like a frankenstein
because i like to i like to get some
electricity going and then you want to
feel like it's massaging you basically
yeah like i i don't know what it is but
he'll he'll be like and then he'll come
back and he'll go french don't don't
touch the knob yeah don't touch the knob
don't leave the knob in the reach
distance of french yeah i've got arms
like a gibbon look at them look at those
gib arms gib arms
you're a oh and a treasure i love you
what i love you too what happened
uh you said it was almost over in the
casino
yeah in your first one which we agree
was a little bit more like this yeah
what
what ended it
and how did it end oh it ended because
we were both sitting in therapy
so you tried you you were yeah we tried
a good go yeah we tried
and we were just sitting in therapy and
ultimately uh the therapist said well
does this maybe feel like it's
over
and then we just kind of looked at each
other
and
nobody said anything and then from that
point it was just sort of over what a
cinematic moment it really was yeah and
then we um we got a mediator because we
didn't want to get a bunch of lawyers in
i just basically told her like you know
take the half you want i don't want any
animosity or anything and so they said
well what we want to do is like we want
to have a post-it picture like post-it
party where you walk around and you each
have a a
certain color of post-it
it's like the opposite of a registry a
marriage registry yeah you did a divorce
registry a divorce register you want to
put this behind you no
not just what the heck i'm good actually
no i no pete this is my space
don't [__] with my space don't don't
don't enter my space pete unless well i
mean
oh
[Laughter]
i'm that way i'm like i'll take
affection in any way in any way anybody
that wants to flirt with me if if a man
i'm not gay but if a man wants to be
like hey i'll be like all right i'm
telling you anytime like a gay man has
ever paid me a compliment i've been like
oh i feel pretty that's like almost the
prettiest you'll ever feel
i'm so with you and i'm a little
embarrassed to admit that all my
musician friends i want them to write
songs about me yes let me tell you about
a funny man
the funny fact
the lanky yet the armed man he is
complete waiting for that yeah and all
my gay friends i'm waiting for them to
be like
look i'm just saying i know we're
friends but right but if it came down to
it and you were feeling like you had a
weird night yeah
you'd be the john candy
i'd eat you first oh defrost and eat you
i don't know i don't know
why this is so amusing to me which was
just all of it the whole thing yeah tell
me where you put the post-its on oh um
you're like at one point you're doing
dumb [__] rubber chicken she's like yeah
she's like mayonnaise yeah she's like
putting it on like a you know a 50 000
piece of art and i like put it on a dog
like a dog walked by and i was just like
oh single ping-pong paddle yeah that's
for
french she's an oriental rug that's
worth a minute and then i do the ball
yeah and then i do the other like and
meanwhile she's like walked off with
everything that's a chandelier but i do
love the mediator i love that you wanted
it to be amicable and i love that you
did was it an even-handed post-it
session it was
you know it ultimately was i mean we we
you know there wasn't any animosity we
still yeah i talked to her last week
yeah but uh
but it's just uh i i think i was i was
with her for 14 years
and uh i think
i don't know maybe that was just my best
before date
like
like i'm like like if you look at a can
i think i'm good for 14.
oh my god canned steward oh that's the
last 14 years oh it's not bad all right
that's not bad it's not bad yet that's a
long time to be with somebody it is yeah
but i was always even before that i was
kind of like a serial monogamist yep
like even any girlfriend it was like two
years or three years or so i was always
about a year and a half with anybody i
always think that um
you know between a relationship i want
to go on a a a [__] about where it's
just like go crawl back a good
old-fashioned [__] about a good
old-fashioned fuckabout
but i
then i get there and i'm not i'm just
not wired that way yeah no i understand
i intimacy guys like it's always been
more
i know like i've always wanted to go in
and brush my teeth while val's in the
bath which is an image i'm really
getting from the movie don't look now
but like i've always just wanted
intimacy and familiarity it's the same
thing i want with my friendships yes i
want safe places i want to co-regulate
um that's right i want a kind face
looking back at me yeah just simple
things yeah yeah
we're buddies now you and i are buds
yeah casual sex was never uh i i
certainly gave it a go and and enjoyed
it yeah but i was never like some people
just seem to do it and they're like this
yeah
this is what i'm into this is it yeah
and then when they get married they're
like
like the bachelor bachelor party where
it's like it's your last chance to have
sex with a stranger i'm like
that's a like that's never made sense to
me either you just found your person and
you're like but one more binge before i
start the diet it really
like
your wife is a diet yeah you're marrying
jenny craig like the bloom is off the
rose like before you've even like done
the vows you're [__] yeah if that's
your bachelor party if the if the
attitude to me is like
like one more steak before i go
vegetarian
like get out of here i i didn't enjoy my
bachelor party like i didn't even want
it like i i don't
i don't enjoy a strip club because i
don't want a woman who's trying to get
through law school staring at me as if
she cares about me that's right i just
don't feel it yeah i don't like it i've
never i've said this many times i've
never been aroused in the strip club and
me either and it's always bachelor
parties where i've where i've been given
the opportunity and i'm always just like
this i think it's because of show
business yeah i'm not calling it bad
acting
but like when valen sorry to be over
sherry but when val and i have sex what
makes it good sex is like is a
connection
trust i'm not saying we can't just have
a good old-fashioned [__] about every
once in a while sure but even that is
like it's real it's just a connection
but somebody just being like first of
all a fake name my name is mercedes yeah
i have a star glittery thing on their
face i'm just like and then suddenly i
have to listen to bon jovi
it's just
why do i why am i listening to brett
michael's all over what did i miss
that so much of the male populace seems
to be like boner time is bon jovi yeah a
girl named xerox
and me sitting next to my friend as i'm
being grounded yeah a bunch of dudes
yeah i don't it's maybe the least erotic
thing i used to have again it's not a
joke like an erotic club to me would be
like a regular
looking person yes
i don't you'd have to like we're on a
bus together and we have like a soul
well that's the thing it's like even any
time like i'm not i'm not like into
porn like i don't no porn i i don't
really enjoy it
but if i if it
if i do if we're like me and my wife
were at a hotel or something
i don't want to see some like flashy
porn i want to see uh
like amateurs yeah real people but i
also don't want to see somebody who
looks like their boyfriend talked them
into a situation you
are my correct specially
you know my this is over sherry i like
amateur and they're by themselves you
know why oh best chance everyone's
having a good time oh that's i'm here
masturbating you're there masturbating
everything's clean let's let it go but i
i forget who has this bit somebody has a
stand-up bit where it's like you hear
some accent that betrays the conceit
like it looks like it's just like fun
bubble bath time and then you hear
someone be like
that's always the hope no it's like
somebody got trafficked yeah or
something you know honestly that's what
you're saying that's that's the the
horrible truth is you're like is this is
this not okay and no one's talking about
it yeah i mean i don't i don't mind like
you know i'm in full support of a
sex worker who just chose their life
right but but if it's a bad situation oh
my gosh there's so much things
and then the minute you become the
father to a daughter
i'm just like my wife is like oh if
anything ever happens you'll go to jail
you know that right like you'll you'll
kill anybody
who uh
compromises you guys yes yeah like taken
i hate it yes yeah that's the whole they
made a whole trilogy based on that that
feeling yeah and that that's one of the
weird things because not to be super
spiritual but who's not your maybe not
your daughter but who's not your sister
that's when it gets complicated you're
like
where and i've actually had people you'd
be surprised i'll talk about porn and
how it i i don't feel great about it and
i've actually had women come up to me
and be like
like [__] you dude like some women like
they're defending the other side like
trying to own other people's sexuality
so i've kind of been yeah maybe i should
stop papooing it one thing's for sure
everyone should be getting paid more
that is something i'm like
adamant about if if 30 rock from this
from the sun was on
uh pornhub
lawsuits up the waze you can't just have
your kitchen nbc owns nbc right yeah
they own that
900 lawyers would be there and shut down
and then make you pay out the nose but
as soon as you shoot a porno it's
uploaded onto a website the next day and
nobody's so somebody who's literally
doing a very difficult everybody
involved is doing a difficult thing yeah
it's like spotify for your body or
something it's just it's spotify it's
spotify it's spotify oh
so even if let's start botify let's not
even even though we're not into porn at
all and you know what
the the the thing that bringing it into
the light and being like these people
should be paid
would do is make it more glaringly
obvious when it is a bad situation yeah
it's like legalizing weed it's like
let's legalize this let's get it out of
the stigma out of the shadows because
people are dying for it people are going
to jail for it livestreams have been
ruined for it i don't i mean there's
still people in jail in texas
for having like a little bit of weed in
like doing like 20 years you know my my
cousin skis
i just wanted to say skis i like saying
skis for my drug dealer name i'm happy
but no it's it's [__] it's a tragedy
it's madness it's madness and that
that's there's there's certainly a a
porn
equivalent that that should happen but
no u.s president will get very far to be
like and the first thing i'm going to do
on your pawn presence i'm going to be
the pawn president i'm going to take the
cobwebs out of the industry i like that
he's from boston i am from uh cheddar
pigwick or whatever that is
uh if you do a uh hardcore porn you get
money you will get money for porn every
time people uh spank it crank it yank it
or dank it dank it
who wrote this teleprompter
in fact i don't even agree with what i'm
saying this is a terrible thing maybe
i'm going to rethink my current
situation
i can't find a running mate oh i've just
received word that i have lost
as soon as you're in the debate it's
like three percent it's not very good
porn stars should be uh compensated sir
we're talking about health care uh it
keeps me healthy
i'll tell you that like
your porn president the porn president
jf
comedy
yeah j
j f kennedy but f is for [__]
yeah yeah that's what it's gonna be
that's a [__] comedy it's yeah [__]
jack off kennedy jack off kevin
why jack off kennedy kennedy i think if
you're enjoying erotic films you should
pay a premium you should pay a premium
and look at my wife she's so embarrassed
right now
look at me right now don't look at me
jack off kennedy and jackie o'face say
is apparently face huh
oh
oh face jackie oh face yeah
oh no
oh i'm really happy with jackie o'face
and jon [__] jack jack off canada jack
off kennedy and jackie office
i mean type it into google yeah you
can't oh they probably no you would you
know i'm not asking you to i'm saying
your fingers won't even do that well you
did she's like look that exists and if
it exists the actors in it aren't being
paid enough
no sure they deserve a bump a bump a
bump after the bumping
damn it we've gone a lot of places
french are we not at 90.
so yeah
oh what a sweet
129 129. well you mentioned that you
don't believe in garsh
no god
um
i believe in a version of god yeah tell
me everything oh this is a safe space to
believe whatever you want i just was
recalling that earlier you said you
weren't religious but you prayed uh for
the sign in the casino i think like i uh
uh i believe
you know when you're on stage and and
and it's going great
and you feel this electricity that's
going back and forth between people
i think that's god
yeah i think that's it's relationship a
relationship and when the air gets just
electric or or
when you say something to somebody and
it
it it
seems to change their day
i think it's an expression i'm like uh
i'm a golden rules christian i'm just
doing to others love the person in front
of you
and then the rest of it i don't pretend
to know if there's a person or if a
thing but yeah
well that's beautiful you know who's on
your side is the old jc
he said well when he said love your
neighbor is yourself and and the rest is
sort of uh details i think that's true i
think the rest is just this guidebook
that that
you know somebody manufactured so
well people were involved in it for sure
yeah there's a whole conversation we
could have about what what i think and
what i've been taught that the gospels
are really saying about self-emptying
self-surrender self-sacrifice dying
before you die being broke and realizing
your true self
that's the deeper message of the gospel
but really if you take away love your
neighbor as yourself because honestly i
don't do a very good job at all of that
look i'm always begging myself up i'm
trying to amass power possessions
prestige that's those are the three
things that jesus preaches against the
most right so i can't say that i'm fully
cooked or fully converted yeah but i can
say i'm doing my best and when it comes
to loving you in this moment that's good
that's pretty great because what you're
saying that energy that relationship
being god i think that's absolutely
right because in those high frequency
moments where groups of people get on
the same page what happens is to me
identities are dropped and a singularity
of identity is that's that's what it is
it's a removal of the distance between
you yes i feel like it's like the number
system it's like if you look at
any number from one to one million or
whatever
uh
you take any number out of it
and it all falls apart
wow but
if you never
each number is special
because without it buddy so there's like
a singular way to put it yeah there's
like a singularity to your life but
you're also a part of a thing and so
don't feel unimportant but yeah um
but know that you're you're
you know a part of a bigger thing that's
kind of the good news is you're special
the bad news is everybody is special i
guess meaning bad news to your ego yeah
ego would like to be special and no one
else that's right but but you're 11 is
only doing 11's job and nobody can do
11's job
i just couldn't have needed to hear this
message for bet more today there's just
something about like i i grew up
christian so i still have that
performance principle yeah like i really
feel like i have to be perfect i feel
like i have to be shiny and nice and
sparkly and earn
my place in the world by being the
golden boy which is what it was like in
my family
and over and over and over again
uh the bible other faiths for sure as
well are going like no
you're a part of a thing
including when things go squirrely yeah
including when things go strange
including when french gets divorced
including when pete gets divorced that
mattered that belonged you know what i
mean yes but in the west we've sort of
turned spirituality into just another
way to win another way to shine and
we've turned it into being nice when
really what you've said i actually think
your golden rule and your number thing
is sort of the whole thing because the
number thing is don't forget you belong
and that's
everybody yeah and everything
and when what hell is is feeling
separate and forgetting that you belong
yes even when you're the guy at the
party that that says the joke that
everybody drops their glass and stares
at you you [__] belonged you were the
guy at that party to them yes and that
butterfly affected everything and every
and this conversation that we're having
goes to these people and these people go
out to those people it's all a swirling
mass of numbers that need one i think i
think you're i think that's it and
and the worst part is is that in three
hours we're gonna have to re-remind
ourselves that's right of this
conversation and that's what i mean by
being fully cooked i think there's a way
to get it into your marrow yeah like i
belong um but there's something and it's
okay i'm the same way val and i talk
about all the time we're like on our
death beds there's a chance we might be
like this i think this might have been
[__] i'm just scared yeah and you
have to go like
uh ultimate reality is not contingent on
how french feels yeah and how pete feels
now i know and we just have to remember
and remember and remember as much as we
can that we're part of something bit
this is something i say to myself all
the time it's from a course in miracles
i go
uh you're never angry for the reason you
think you are
you're angry because you think the world
is meaningless
uh god did not create a meaningless
universe and sometimes i just say the
third one god did not create a
meaningless universe and that's just
another way of saying i'm a number in a
sequence yes and it's not meaningless
and it's not i i have a purpose i'm
important but i'm also a part of a a
large of a thing of everything your
identity is relational you're only
french because i'm looking at you and i
go what do i call you yeah you know what
i mean yeah exactly that's why we made
the thing called french steward and
that's why i made the thing called pete
might as well be uh you know ketchup or
ketchup and mustard yeah ketchup and
mushrooms the old dill the old dual
ketchup you can be ketchup
oh you want to be mustard french is
mustard
you're male french is mustard and katie
mayo katie mayo
i wish your name was patty mayo
you were so patient
she
katie how many we've done 600 i'm just
turning this off
620 episodes so multiply that by two
hours minimum each that's how many of
them all together yeah katie's been
there for almost everyone aristotle
every once in a while
it's totally tony every once in a while
but almost always sweet baby jesus but
you know
not to be weird but every morning i put
katie on i do gratitude lists i don't
know if if you've gotten into that it's
wonderful and it's great i i list the
people
that that's the best thing to be
grateful to i'm talking about the number
thing yes you go i could say i'm
grateful for the podcast but what is the
podcast it's french it's katie obviously
it's katie it's it's joe who edits the
video yeah it's it's it's all these
different people and i love
that that helped me get in touch with
gratitude is not just like
abstract ideas you actually just put
names of people oh there you go katie
deal with that that's so direct it's
like it's great that's really a great
idea but it rem it reminds you
you're one of the numbers they're one of
the numbers and
all the numbers need one another and
it's it's it's your definition of god
it's which is great isn't it interesting
i i grew up my mother was uh uh
still she was a christian scientist so i
didn't really see a doctor till i was
like 24 or something no way and there's
a there's a lot of it that i'm you know
i've just kind of become my own thing
but
but there's one thing that that i'll say
in the morning which is uh
they call it the seven synonyms of god
which is principle mind soul spirit life
truth love
and that part of it works for me that's
right that's that's that's all i need
right there just just a little something
to be like
walk me through that it's the seven
principles it's the seven synonyms of
god so these all mean god yes
and it's principle
mind
soul
spirit
life
truth
love
i'm it's very in line with what i
believe too because not to be
why would i apologize for this we've
been very woo i think god is what's
looking out your eyes right now yeah
it's awareness yes and it's what we all
are
and
so talk about my gratitude journal i do
affirmations in it too and the last one
always is i trust myself capital s
itself i i trust
not just god as an idea of some guy
swirling up around with a big beard yeah
yeah i trust my my ultimate self
my deep my truest identity yeah but if
you reduce me down to the point where
you can't reduce me anymore what's left
is the spark and god is the fire and i'm
a little spark but really a little spark
is the whole thing too
you know what i'm saying yeah i really
can't divide infinity if you take a
little piece of infinity and put it in
me and put it in you yeah you can't have
a little piece of infinity going back to
everything it's the whole thing it's a
whole thing so when you die and i can't
say this enough i i've had some
experiences that showed me this when you
die you're actually going in you're
actually dropping all that's fake all
that sort of goes away yeah and in my
experience you're losing the physical
car you're losing the car
but the passenger remains like the meal
yeah
yeah you're you're retiring that's what
rondas would say there's right there
he's like you're selling your old dodge
van yeah that's why they say they
dropped the body but you're not going
out to heaven you're actually going
where you were the whole time and
there's nothing more beautiful than that
because that means frenchie we're both
there already and that's what jesus and
others were always saying the kingdom of
heaven is in you the kingdom of heaven
is nigh it's here yeah it won't come by
expectation they won't say here it comes
it's here but men do not see it people
do not see it yeah but when we have
conversations like this you sort of
remember right well yeah in 30 minutes
we'll forget and then 30 minutes
but i love it pete like i just uh it's
been such a pleasure just to uh you know
get to know uh a new friend yeah man
that's the whole thing yeah now we're
friends now we're friends sealed yeah i
hear you good luck with that
good luck with me pete good luck and you
too 3 a.m french texts yeah
well this has been great do you feel
satisfied i talked a lot there i feel
wonderful okay good i i it's just i
loved it i'm glad we have one last
question oh okay and it's for you
because because in the god section i do
tend to lie i like to talk about that
stuff so we always want to end with you
can you tell me a time in your life
where you laughed
really really really really hard it
doesn't have to be a good story maybe
you and your wife somebody farted maybe
someone fell down yeah maybe you were a
kid
maybe your your dad
closed the car door in his hand it
doesn't have to be a great story just if
you have tears streaming down your face
where where do you go to what happened
my wife and i call this uh
one time she uh
and i can't exactly remember what it was
but she made me laugh so hard
that i i splurped my coffee onto my
pants splurped yeah and so now
whenever we really make each other laugh
really hard yes we call it like oh you
splurped me
intimacy you know you splurped me this
is it and so she'll text it like i'll
i'll i'll send her something or whatever
something that gets her you swiped and
it's like you know we
i i don't even know what the joke would
be but it's like oh splorp no that's all
i need isn't that the best you went
right to the heart of it yes what i want
is relationship intimacy how are you
using these things to bond and stuff
that's beautiful val and i have a
similar relationship in that way yeah
and
we don't have we don't say sport but
maybe now we will but but we also like
sometimes she'll be like uh
you know that joke's only for me right
like you can't take that to the street
i'm like no i know i know she's like
you're you're old
you're
old ellen's just for the kitchen that
was just for the kitchen
and don't test that in 2022 that's right
you're you're alec baldwin
that's right
you baldwin
sport me don't
baldwin always splurp
well frenchie that's a wonderful answer
i'm looking at my notes leno
oh cindy i i wrote down that you did the
cindy crawford talk show who cares we
share the same birthday you and cindy
february 20th are you still close
every every every year on our birthday
i'll just i'll send her like a happy
birthday
no does she reply
sometimes
just a gift of her drinking pepsi
i mean talk about
the choice of a new generation yeah that
was the choice of an older generation i
swear she's a lovely human too i believe
it yeah yeah like some of them like you
see like a supermodel and you you meet
them and you're like oh but you're
you're ugly inside i think right but
she's she's not she's just beautiful
look it could be hindsight but i feel
like if you were like she's a terrible
person i would be like really and you
saying that she's a lovely person i'm
kind of like that feels right to me yeah
i don't know i feel like i spent so much
of my youth that's not a joke i'm not
saying like i was staring at her like
looking she was such a part of my
adolescence that i'm like i'd be shocked
something about her essence seems to
come through yeah now she's delightful
it's great she does not leno you and we
full circle no shouldn't land on me okay
um well don't forget the person that
takes the picture is the person you eat
that's right
i'll let you know how it does
all right like i'm gonna need footage oh
yeah
like just but all right well maybe if i
can get this i love it yeah i'll
instagram it and i'll say french steward
and i wrote this joke together oh well i
appreciate it but it's a it's also uh
it's a gift to you it's a it's a it's an
act of love it's a mitzvah yeah it's a
mitzvah there we are yeah well thanks
for being the eight to my nine or you're
the i'm the nine to your ten hey
i'm the three to your four it could go
anyway you zoom out far enough it's just
a bunch of bees it's just a bunch of
stuff
that's right
when you say keep it crispy it's how we
end the guest says the catchphrase keep
it crispy yeah and if you want you can
say it like your character used to from
third rock everybody loves that all
right
hey man
keep it crispy
crazy i don't know why
it was i can do another one right back
keep it crispy
even better like a big
yeah like a bear or something like a big
bear man keep it crispy oh keep
christmas hey bubba keep it crispy hey
baby hey man what's that john c reilly
hey
yeah yeah all right all right keep it
crispy
[Music]